what up guys goes I'm here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the wizard king julius
nova chrono we always knew that the
wizard king was overpowered and if you
watch the anime you know that the wizard
king just died now I love the wizard
king and a part of me wishes he didn't
die but nonetheless the way in which he
died truly impressed me and in this
video i will explore why that is the
case I will look at how Tabata
skillfully kills off an overpowered
character if you want to see more black
clover videos on this channel make sure
to smash that like button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell so you don't
miss any new videos and without further
ado let's jump into it before we get
into the fight between the wizard King
and Patri who calls himself licked let's
look at an example from the seven deadly
sins where an overpowered character is
set up only for his overpowered Ness to
be undermined this happens a lot in the
seven deadly sins now don't get me wrong
I loved the seven deadly sins but often
a character is set up as overpowered
only to be quickly defeated by a
stronger character and so on and so on
the previously overpowered character is
sacrificed to establish the overpowered
nests of another character and the cycle
continues this can be very entertaining
but it also serves to undermine the
defeated characters strength which was
being hyped up as recently as a chapter
ago skip to the numbers shown on the
screen if you want to avoid some seven
deadly sins manga spoilers I'll give you
a few seconds three two one
all right if you're still with me let's
look at an example of how seven deadly
sins introduced and hyped up a character
only to later have that character serve
as a way to hype up another character to
illustrate my point let's take a look at
the character called the original demon
aka the sinner
I remember reading the chapter in which
the original demon first made his
appearance and I went absolutely crazy
over how insanely powerful the
characters seemed to be at that point in
time it was actually the first seven
deadly sins video I personally made
because I couldn't help but talk about
it if you didn't know the original demon
is diffused or is
form of Chandler and Cusack even alone
each of these demons was hyped up to be
extremely powerful when speaking about
them Merlin said that they are
celebrated among the demon clan for
being the absolute strongest of all not
counting the demon king himself they're
said to be strong without equal fast
beyond compare and tougher than any
other each one of them had a power level
higher than that of Mel Yodas when he
entered assault mode when his power
level was measured at 140 mm Cusack was
measured at one hundred and sixty eight
thousand and Chandler at one hundred and
seventy-three thousand these are two of
the highest power levels that are
recorded in the series and it's not even
them at their full power so they're
already presented as being ridiculously
powerful before their fusion so you can
imagine how powerful they must be after
their fusion a fusion could
theoretically multiply their powers
together or at the very least add them
together which would still be the
highest power level we've seen up to
that point in the manga when he appears
Merlin says that her s Kannur and Ludo
shall all strong characters in their own
right have completely lost all chance of
victory the original demon was so strong
that he even challenged the demon king
of the past a figure with godlike power
in the world of the seven deadly sins
yet despite all this hype he is one
shotted by mile after he regains the
ability sunshine
thus he sacrificed to set up miles new
level of power and soon enough mile with
sunshine who just wrecked the legendary
original demon proves to be powerless
against the demon king
thus overpowered characters continuously
have their power undermined in order to
establish the following character as
overpowered this is usually how it works
however this is not what happens with
the wizard King the wizard King is
quickly established as the overpowered
character in the black clover world the
title wizard King itself goes to the
strongest magic knight in the clover
kingdom a kingdom filled with talented
magic Knights like William von gents
Yami Fugo Leon and so on the leader of
The Midnight Sun knows he is fighting
the strongest magic knight in the land
and he thinks he can win so you know
this is going to be an epic fight right
from the get-go the Midnight Sun leader
even has light magic a magic type that
is presented as being time Magic's
weakness because as he says light is the
only thing that can oppose time yet even
when he has the type disadvantage
Julius proves to be too powerful for
Patri even though light magic is
supposed to be the fastest Patri can't
keep up with Julius when he gets a
little serious Patri is shocked he can't
believe that a human can be so powerful
he notices that the wizard king is
trying to restrain him without killing
him meaning he has strength to spare
keep in mind
Patri is a strong opponent he is the
leader of the Midnight Sun meaning he is
the mastermind behind the enemy
organization and has been causing
trouble since volume 1 of the manga he
also has a rare and very powerful form
of magic called light magic light magic
was possessed by the first ever wizard
King so you know it has great potential
Patri has a four-leaf clover another
sign of a powerful mage and he is even
an elf
and elves tend to have an immense amount
of magic power compared to humans my
point is Patri is super strong in all of
these ways and yet he's dumbstruck by
how powerful the wizard king is this all
surge to hype up the wizard Kings power
even more yet he dies he loses the
battle but interestingly enough he
manages to maintain his opie reputation
in the process Patri releases the magic
he has sealed and uses it all to make it
rain light magic blades down on the
people of the Capitol he knows that he
can't win against Julius fair-and-square
Patri says to the wizard king even if I
can't kill you
I can kill everyone around you and quote
since he can't handle the wizard king he
decides to play dirty
he sends his attack at the innocent
people of the capital
Julius could let the people die and
easily defeat Patri however he decides
to save them he chooses to pass on his
dream of a clover Kingdom without
discrimination with equal possibilities
for all to
next generation he uses a time reversal
magic spell to stop the insanely
powerful attack Patri just released thus
saving all those people in the capital
however julius had to waste all of his
magic power to do it and Patri takes
advantage of this and gives the
finishing blow to julius as Patri tells
julius his one weakness was being the
wizard king in other words he would have
been pretty much invincible
if Patri hadn't played dirty and
threatened the well-being of the people
of the kingdom you might be wondering
why julius didn't go all out from the
beginning instead of giving pachi the
opportunity to endanger the whole
kingdom in the first place well the
answers most likely because the leader
of the Midnight Sun was using the body
of William bond Jets Julius is precious
student and friend if you watch Naruto
you know that the Third Hokage let his
student Orochimaru go in the past he
couldn't bring himself to kill him even
though he was clearly a dangerous
villainous character that decision
turned out to be his undoing
Orochimaru came back to destroy the
village and the Third Hokage had to
sacrifice his life to stop him Julius
situation is even more problematic
because his precious student William is
a nice person Julius thinks that even
the fact that he helped Patri is a sign
of his kindness and that William is
still rooting for him to win inside
Patras body for these reasons he didn't
want to kill Patri because it would mean
killing his student who in the wizard
king's view only committed the crime of
being too kind that is likely why he
hesitated to kill Patri and didn't want
to go all-out that is why he was trying
to restrain him without killing him he
still was hoping to save William a
person he had rescued many years before
from a life of pain and discrimination
even as Julius is dying we are told in
the manga that the strongest magic
Knight sinks into the Twilight so in the
end
Julius died while maintaining his
overpowered status he wasn't simply
hyped up and then overpowered by his
opponent in order to help build that
character's reputation rather he proved
to be stronger than his opponent in a
fair fight he was undefeated and when he
died he was our
we the strongest character in the manga
up to that point it was his philosophy
not a lack of power that led to his
death he lived his life trying to save
and protect people he wanted to protect
them from physical threats but also from
discrimination based on their social
status it was the wish he had to protect
everyone and build a future free from
discrimination that led to his downfall
he sacrificed himself for his dream and
a dream lives on in the next generation
in the people he placed his faith in and
in the people they placed their faith in
in turn the wizard King's dream lives on
in people like auste who also want to
create a world without discrimination
and with opportunity for all even for
those who happen to be coming from the
per se caen realm or from a different
country altogether
keep in mind julius came a long way when
he was rising to power
that's when zara the first commoner
magic knight was killed by his own
teammates were trying to be a magic
knight
even though he came from a low social
standing by the time julius died he had
not only normalized the idea of a
commoner being a magic knight but he had
also placed a bastard from the forsaken
realm William and a foreigner Yami in
extremely high-ranking positions he made
them magic knight captains that is
pretty much the highest title he could
give them besides the title of the
wizard King itself he made huge leaps
towards his dream and paved the way for
people like ASSA to fully carry it out I
believe that this is a very skilled way
for a mangaka to kill off a truly
overpowered character the character
remains a respected character even Patri
the person who killed him
said he respects Julius the character
keeps his overpowered status the
character dies for a cause greater than
himself the character passes on his
dream to his successors so in a way he
will always be present in the story even
after he dies I'm not saying that every
overpowered character has to die in
exactly this way but I think that with
Julius is death tabatha really did a
great job it was even more emotional
because he didn't have to die he chose
to in order to save the others and keep
his wish
going the death even had huge stakes
the leader of the enemy organization
killed the wizard King the strongest
magic knight and in the process cut off
the head of the clora kingdom not only
does that lead the way for possible
chaos it also shows that no one is
really safe
the wizard king is a symbol a symbol of
peace and safety the people of the
kingdom can rest easy knowing that no
matter what happens the wizard king will
be able to take care of the threat
however when he dies that illusion
disappears and with it comes the
realization that things really could and
horribly for the whole kingdom for all
these reasons Julius's death is one of
the most meaningful and one of my
favourite deaths in anime you can tell a
lot about a character by the way in
which they die rather than undermining
him Julius's death solidifies his image
as a powerful great and kind dreamer he
never gave up on his ideals like so many
people do over the course of their life
after years of being told to grow up and
be realistic even up to the age of 40
Julius stood fast and his ideals and
always maintained his sense of childish
wonder just look at how excited he still
got whenever he saw new forms of magic a
lot of people understandably still wish
that Julius didn't die but even so you
can't help but appreciate the fact that
Tabata found a way to kill off an
overpowered character while adding to
their greatness rather than taking away
from it in the end
Julius because of and not in spite of
his death will go down as one of my
favorite characters in anime he serves
as a spectacular role model for not only
his successors in the anime but for us
the viewers as well and we can and
should all learn from his great example
and that is it for today's video if you
enjoyed the video make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
have and be sure to subscribe for more
black clover videos and possibly more
videos in this series make sure to
comment down below if you want to keep
seeing how to kill off an overpowered
character videos and we can cover other
epic characters who had epic deaths that
serve to solidify their legacy rather
than tarnish it so here's a question for
you guys today what do you think are
some of the best written deaths in
anyways as you can tell by this video I
get inspired by anime on a daily basis
if you're like me then I strongly
recommend you check out our selection of
anime inspired shirts at anime uproar
comm we have original designs like auste
dream big work hard along with many
others I wear these shirts a lot and the
two main reasons are because I love
anime and because they remind me to be
the best version of myself so if that
sounds cool to you definitely check them
out at anime AFRICOM link in the
description you can get even more
inspiring content and crucial updates on
our twitter and instagram at anime
uproar a big big thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our procureur
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson and King
zelgius and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans baby ray a
seventeen FF DP Steven Ingrid ah a Lola
and autumn Mattie Mac 239 and makoto-kun
and the patron who transcends greatness
itself Regan Harrison the one who has
been acknowledged by Lord we go himself
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
slash anime uproar and becoming a patron
today for as little as one dollar if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these kings and
queens right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
and until next time see you space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]